and children
about the Aquaman the man of aqua which
I guess is hydro man from marvel Aquaman
created by Mort wise agreed many years
ago recreated lovingly by James Wan and
his crew for the 2018 blockbuster
Aquaman can you believe this movie is
about 750 million right now Aquaman's
can make a billion dollars go back in
time and tell somebody that that Aquaman
is gonna make a billion dollars makes
sense now
because my god visually sumptuous
Aquaman is everything a movie is
supposed to be when you put down your
two bits or 10 bucks or 20 depending on
where you go you want to escape take me
somewhere show me some [ __ ] I had never
seen before that's what you want in a
movie I never made movies like that I
was like I'm gonna show you a
convenience store something you saw
probably right before you went to the
cinema talented filmmakers like James
Wan take you diving into the ocean to
show you a world you ain't never seen
before
same way James Gunn Marvel owned outer
space took us a space with guardians
galaxies and claimed outer space as
their own James Wan and DC and Warner
Brothers have now claimed the seas for
themselves with Aquaman before I go any
further what are you doing New Year's
Eve that's tomorrow night we had to
Babylon shows that's right this review
is sponsored by Hollywood babble-on you
see there's me and Ralph as SpongeBob
and Patrick behind me Hollywood
babble-on
man we have two shows on New Year's Eve
December 30 verse that's tomorrow 7:30
show and then there's a 10:00 o'clock
show and that takes us all the way to
the ball drop and the countdown and all
that good stuff let's end this wretched
year together man so if you're anywhere
near California right now Hollywood
improv the world-famous Hollywood improv
tomorrow night new years of babble leave
with me and Ralph Carmen come out and
see it tickets at cease mod.com SE e sm
OD calm okay
we just hit my [ __ ] 40mm this [ __ ]
make your dick hard [ __ ] tease that's
from a movie um okay this Aquaman VII
that was tava by the way I'm not I'm not
very hard drinker at all this is
essentially tea just [ __ ] black tea
with no milk sugar in it so doesn't make
anything hard okay Aquaman Jason Momoa
is Aquaman but a little backstory on
Aquaman for those who've come in late
Aquaman created by Mort wise again for
DC back in the day has long been
considered a joke you know for for
adults and stuff of all the superheroes
people always give him [ __ ] Seinfeld's
got some bits I think on Aquaman maybe
I'm wrong
Aquaman was the hero that you know there
were like Oh [ __ ] for fighting a
shark we'll let you know Aquaman great
character and you know inhabits the
oceans which you know the endless font
of story possibilities but you know at
the end of the day you know orange shirt
green pants Aryan hair you know really
looks like a young Hitler Youth back in
the day you know it just the good
character was part of the Super Friends
and the Justice League of course but
generally you know speaking and also ran
to Batman and Superman by the way look
at his sweet DC shirt right there men
anatomy of a DC even got that from to
public Aquaman is represented with the
leg look at that leg so what happens
with the character of Aquaman is we got
with credit where credit's due
Peter David in his run of Aquaman and he
did the Atlantis Chronicles as well in
comic book form back in the
maybe late eighties early nineties
probably early 90s he's the one that
turned Aquaman into a badass like all
credit where credit's due
you know the Justice League cartoon did
as well but they followed suit what was
going on in the comics at the time Peter
David like you know turned Aquaman into
into a bad boy
dad piranhas eat his hand off and so he
had like a harpoon hand at one point
okay and a lot of people say yeah okay
but it's a harpoon and stuff I took his
shirt off you know like look at a bare
chest at Aquaman and stuff it was it was
pretty pretty big changes for the sea
king back in the day that's what we're
seeing up on the screen you know all the
people who used to make Aquaman jokes
and whatnot
forgot that for like a good 10 year
stretch that Justice League cartoon was
putting an Aquaman up there that was you
know a badass Atlantean Sea King not
like you know the dude who was like
which to be fair I love I still do that
whenever I'm near a body of water that's
the Aquaman it's talking to the sea life
on the Superfriends
so Peter David turns him into this
badass character then years later Jason
Momoa plays called Drago on on Game of
Thrones and somebody has the good sense
Oliver's ex Neider who said let's cast
him as Aquaman there's a version Aquaman
that's like a badass right let's go with
this guy what a great choice man this
Momoa he's just made for movies I met
him on playing super nice dude man super
[ __ ] tall dude I met him twice Evan
playing actually just so I'm fairly
recently as well slept on the same plane
with him didn't realize woke up in the
morning looked oh he said hey looked
over this Jason Momoa I was like I slept
with Jason Momoa all night long he made
me wet I don't even know it so anyway
wonderful [ __ ] dude this guy has all
the spirit and the umph to play this
version of the character and and of
course he has the physical presence to
say the least this is called Drago
remember oh he saw you know that amazing
performance so props to Schneider I
think Zack Snyder is the one that is
like let's do this cuz you know that
that happened back in what Batman V
Superman and then he wasn't Justice
League Aquaman been in two movies before
now but not like this like they got it
right third time was the charm this
movie is a charmer so right then and
there you know your your Aquaman your
central character is interesting easy to
look at fun he's got an edge to him and
stuff you got to remember this guy had
one of the best moments in Justice
League which I know for a lot of people
isn't saying much but remember he's
sitting there he starts talking about
like I'm young I don't want to die
should I want to do blah blah and then
he turns out he's sitting on the Wonder
Woman's lasso of truth he's a charmer
man he can polish it off so they made
the right choice at casting this guy but
they made the really right choice in
going after the director man James Wan
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this kids talented and I
talked to him on the IMDB yeah the IMD
boat if you will for comic-con last year
just when they dropped the trailer and I
was like you're doing the Lord's work
and sucked him off not for reals but
like about his work and I said dude you
make autumn look like a warm ocean
master looks like ocean master Black
Manta looks like Black Manta like and I
saw at that point we didn't see the
footage yet of Arthur and his full
regalia but there's a Lego sculpture of
Arthur wearing the orange shirt and I
was like word is he wears the orange
shirt in this movie like what the [ __ ]
happened how did you get away with this
and he said there was no point in
changing the designs he's gone those
designs have lasted decades classic
wonderful designs so BAM like we'd kept
with with with what it looks like and it
does Black Manta looks like Black Manta
many things look like the way they do in
the comic books or if not exactly pretty
darn close
so James but like created a star
it's like a Star Wars type adventure
it's not like you know I'm not saying
it's Star Wars good but boy oh boy it
creates a universe and brings you right
into it and stuff there's a lot of world
building you know warning spoilers two
hours and 20 minutes of Aquaman that is
James as prepared a seafood buffet and
you're not allowed to leave until it's
all done man so yeah just know that
going in there's a lot of [ __ ]
Aquaman to unpack they they just it's
all the Aquaman ever and if you have the
feeling when they were making the movie
like they were like look let's throw in
everything and the kitchen sink because
this one shot the only shot where we're
gonna have to make [ __ ] Aquaman so we
can't leave anything undone like they
used to of his biggest foes in this
first movie both ocean master is
half-brother arm and Black Manta who in
the comics spoilers like spoilers
countdown 5 4 if you don't want to know
this 3 2 1
Black Manta kills his son Arthur curry
son aqua aqua baby not Aqualad mera like
at one band that drives me insane in the
comics at one point you know there's
rich material here and they chose to
kind of do with it what you know the
considering Jason Momoa comes from Game
of Thrones this is a very underwater
Game of Thrones type of movie it's about
houses and Lords and and kingdoms and
and you know trident that are old and
have magic powers and [ __ ] like that
like all stuff comes straight out to
comic books and all stuff that I'm sure
you know landlubbers and newbies to
Aquaman or like oh my god what whoo who
thought of all this stuff it all comes
from the comic books even right down to
one point there's a shot of the octopus
playing like in a band that Aquaman had
a little sidekick name took both octopus
and there's even a panel of one point in
the comics of him playing a bunch of
instruments like there there's a lot of
love for the source material in this
movie and boy did they spend all
money holy [ __ ] they spent a buck or two
over two hundred million somebody said
200 million [ __ ] even if it's under my
hair under two hundred million let's say
it was 150 but it's not it's 200 million
it's a lot of fog and oh man and you see
it all up on the screen like you got to
imagine can't shoot my [ __ ]
underwater talking to each other we
talked about its podcast mean Scott
Mosier during uh I think it was Justice
League or Batman V Superman ah suck
bubble you know well the sudden water
goes away and people are talking to each
other and a [ __ ] suck bubble they
don't do that and this [ __ ]
just talk underwater and we all know
that can't be done in real life and we
all you know people's hair underwater
you can't control it
so every shot underwater in this movie
is in effect so you know like there must
have green-screen their hair or whatever
the [ __ ] so all their hair was replaced
same way and like Batman V Superman and
Justice League machines in the Zack
Snyder stuff he would do the capes
digitally he would do Superman's cape
digitally as [ __ ] wearing a cape man and
won't behave the way I wanted to we'll
do it in post they did that with
everybody's [ __ ] hair underwater
that's expensive you know the last time
water brother spent this much on [ __ ]
hair and CG was when they took off Henry
Calvin's mustache this costs even more
because they had to put hair on
everybody underwater and let the hair
move and stuff hats off to the CG crew
on this the effects crew holy [ __ ] what
a lot of work could you imagine if
you're that cat that's like I went to
the Dave school man to learn how to do
effects and whatnot and my I spent two
years doing
amber herds underwater hair like that's
that's somebody's reality man and hats
off to them because [ __ ] that [ __ ]
looked amazing like it looked like they
were underwater like it's crazy just get
used to it at a certain point but you
forget what goes into it the technical
craftsmanship pretty astounding so they
spent a lot of money on this flick and
it shows it's all up there on the screen
nobody could ever say like [ __ ] where'd
the money go it's up there what happens
in the movie shall we go
it opens with like a sweet little
prologue that tells the story of how
Aquaman was born to [ __ ] story yeah man
it's like lady gets coughed up by the
sea and Atlantis Queen the queen of
Atlantis and a lighthouse keeper and her
become friends and and it's like splash
but dirtier because then they wind up
Bonin cuz Atlanta people from Atlantis
aren't like you know we're [ __ ] fish
people while some of them are as we saw
in the movie but you know it was a
different continent just like you know
us North America or whatever [ __ ] and
then it was dropped into the sea so you
know thinking they got legs and you
could happen I mean it couldn't happen
but like the the sci-fi of it makes
sense that they have a kid together
because she's an Atlantean but
technically human right I mean somebody
tell me I'm wrong
in any event mm-hmm they have a kid but
she gotta get the [ __ ] out of there
because Atlantis has come looking for
and she's jeopardizing the kid's life so
she tells her boy Valco who's the Willem
Dafoe you you look out for him and raise
him and [ __ ] like that she goes back to
Atlantis like volcko raises young
Aquaman you see this done through a
series of flashbacks it's not a linear
film like in terms of like we start when
he's a child then we end in the present
they they kind of go back and forth so
you pick all this up along the way
volcko was training him to like you know
be the man from Atlantis which was a TV
show Patrick Duffy and then he goes to
Atlantis parently in Atlantis was like
[ __ ] you half-breed you muggle and they
bounced him out of Atlantis so that's
why he was all like [ __ ] Atlantis in
those other two movies we saw him in
Justice League Batman V Superman like
remember he's talking to mirror and he's
like [ __ ] Atlantis that's why apparently
they didn't like him and Atlantis didn't
like his mom either the Queen they
[ __ ] tossed her in the drink man out
into the the pits the the trench you
know where she was presumably eaten or
killed or whatever the [ __ ] for the
crime of cohabitating with a human being
and Megan a half-breed kid or whatever
but spoilers she ain't dead Nicole
Kidman lives ladies and gentlemen just
like Michelle Pfeiffer in ant-man she
been hiding in the quantum realm the
underwater quantum realm and she also
has a funny mask to be like it's me
Nicole Kidman just like Michelle
Pfeiffer's I could it's me
Catwoman so uh yeah our adventure begins
with Aquaman helping a sub out a sub
that's being attacked by pirates these
pirates afford the backstory for a Black
Manta because it's Black Manta and his
dad are the Pirates and then his dad
gets killed while fighting Aquaman and
so the David his son you know it's like
I hate Aquaman and he's already in
league with armed to like scare the
atlantis folks into war with the surface
world cuz there's a cool shot of life
look at all this garbage Atlantis has
thrown the [ __ ] garbage back up out
of the ocean and now it's on the landed
ship that was cool and fortunately it
was just one quick moment I wish that
had been the whole [ __ ] plot like a
garbage fight with Atlantis like [ __ ]
you here's your [ __ ] tampons back
applicators so arm is using Black Manta
to like scare the tribes if you will
whatever of Atlantis the kingdoms of
Atlantis into joining into a war with
the surface world it's time we take on
the service world and orem once he gets
everyone collected he will become the
ocean master man man in a minute man
that's the character's name in comics
ocean mastery where's uh where's this
mask that you know covers his face like
this badass looking in the movie when
Patrick Wilson azorín puts it on its
expressive so his eyes like move and
[ __ ] like that it's dope they spared no
[ __ ] expense on this movie boy did
they [ __ ] put of the old lolly on
they went into Davy Jones locker and
took every [ __ ] doubloon and put it
right up on the screen so
Aquaman you know in the background black
mantas being born he says to the
Atlantis folks to Hermes like get me a
[ __ ] suit man and so they give him a
prototype suit which is the black mantas
suit and for a long time black man's a
fan like myself you know my work I put
Black Manta and ocean master into my
Batman runs in DC in my green arrow run
in DC I used Black Manta fighting
Aquaman you know and that's when green
arrow shows up in Aquaman see green
arrow for the first time went out but it
was it was Black Manta and the manta ray
ship and [ __ ]
but it was the Black Manta of the moment
and he had gone from being a human to
being an actual [ __ ] living manta ray
thanks to a deal with neuron and
underworld unleashed it's a lot of
geekery right there so in any event I
love black man I've tried to put him in
the Superman movie I wrote years ago
it's a great time to be Black Manta fan
me and get cool statues of my [ __ ] like
that James Wan did not change his
ridiculous helmet he wasn't like let's
make him look [ __ ] decent no man he
made it made sense it's like it's gonna
armors head and it's where it's got like
the lasers come out and [ __ ] so he needs
more space hence it looks stupid so Mira
comes to you know Arthur and says hey
man [ __ ] Atlantis is on the brink of
war of the surface world you got to come
back and he's like [ __ ] Atlantis they go
to Atlantis anyway in Atlantis I think
he gets arrested this is all like one
year after Steppenwolf attacked
injustice in the very memorable Justice
League so uh so I'm trying to figure
look at my notes and what happened or
goes down - I mean Aquaman goes down to
Atlantis and then he gets [ __ ]
arrested by his brother warm and you
know he's like we're [ __ ] they killed
our mother because they share a mother
that's his half brother or man Aquaman
or half brothers they share the mother
Nicole Kidman Atlanta Atlanta Atlanta so
he was like [ __ ] you let's fight in the
Ring of Fire
then they have a fight a mirror saves
him with some [ __ ] and she does that
she saves a Aquaman's dad - with Aqua
Kinesis I love that [ __ ] in the comics
she got she controls water with her
make it powerful and [ __ ] make suck
bubbles where you can talk in them and
breathe and [ __ ] or she could also just
kill you with water so mirror comes to
fine saves them and then they go to the
Sarah and because you know Aquaman in
the desert because that's an interesting
notion
so they find an old message where some
old cking are king of Atlantis is like
you got to find the [ __ ] tried and if
you got to try to you got this so they
go off to find the trident
mera and Aquaman they goes meet the sea
the trench monsters this beautiful
[ __ ] shop movies gorgeous kids like
if you're in a beautiful look at movies
[ __ ] I'll commands for you the trench
monsters even they wind up going into a
[ __ ] black hole or a war pole or
whatever if wormhole then it takes him
to like the land that time forgot
remember that movie where there's
dinosaurs in the middle of the earth and
[ __ ] like that so that's where surprise
Nicole Kidman's been hiding out with
Michelle Pfeiffer all these years so you
know they're like hey man in order to
get the Trident you got to go talk to
the Leviathan and the Leviathan has
played no kidding no [ __ ] I should you
not buy Julie Andrews it's not Mary
Poppins but she is in Aquaman she's the
voice of the I forget what the big
leviathans name is homeboy gets the
Trident but this is after of course he
faced down Black Manta like on their
search for it and stuff they they they
Aquaman a mirror and earn Sicily and
black mantas shows up in an incredible
[ __ ] sequence where he's just trying
to kill [ __ ] Aquaman and you're
watching Black Manta fight Aquaman on
the big screen and you're like what an
age of wonder we live in I'm so glad I
lived this long then I got to see a
cinematic Black Manta now I know some
people like how about maybe like you're
happy to live this long to see the cure
of diseases and of course that goes that
saying but the [ __ ] I live for is like
[ __ ] like this where it's like look at
black man's on a big screen so
fantastic sequence if you're a Black
Manta fan even if you're not brilliant
action sequence well put together and
sanely well look like it costs a lot and
took a lot of time to shoot so hats off
to those folks anyway he gets the
Trident they go back down to Atlantis
and [ __ ] like that and there's a big ol
fight worm has been collecting all the
kingdoms you know to try to go up and
fight the service world King dolph
lundgren who was Mira's dad mirror
really believes in Aquaman you know you
got do this you'd be something more than
a king or your own [ __ ] the whole time
I'm like why not you like you do this
like you know you go find the Trident to
you know where it is like you don't need
this guy but you know we do because the
title is Aquaman but they find the
Trident and go down and and fight have
the most metal [ __ ] fight like at one
point war has taken on a king of the
crustaceans so there's this underwater
war people riding [ __ ] sharks and
giant sea horses Aquaman a giant
seahorse and [ __ ] looks like the side of
a van in the 70s like a [ __ ]
seventies ottoman cover just beautiful
underwater war and the knock man shows
up at the trident [ __ ] everyone's then
it comes with Leviathan people oh who is
this [ __ ] man
I guess that's a bit like Avatar when he
showed up at the giant bird and [ __ ]
like oh he's got the [ __ ] giant bird
by the nuts let's follow this son of a
[ __ ] so then King dolph lundgren is
like you know what truly he is the son
of God or whatever [ __ ] and he finally
decides to join up with Aquaman and [ __ ]
off - arm arm
Aquaman fights arm with tridents and
[ __ ] and he's got to drop on him because
the third act of the movie and and he's
the girl and he's gonna kill him but no
no he won't kill him and [ __ ] and arm is
all like sad because I'm happy because
he found out his mom's alive Aquaman's
like our mothers alive and I saved her
from the trench she saved herself but I
brought her back from the trench you
didn't even [ __ ] think to look for a
jerk-off think about that your watery
prison and [ __ ] so they don't kill him
which is something I like and they also
didn't kill Black Manta man he lived to
fight another day the bad guys don't get
killed in this movie unless they're
nameless faceless [ __ ] like so
it's it's good Fleck there's a lot there
to digest man like but I ain't
complainin I'm not sitting there going
like here's what I would have done
different if I would have done anything
different but look my version Aquaman
will cost about 10 million bucks and it
wouldn't look that good so I don't
listen to anything I say but you know it
was a little chunky in the time
Department like [ __ ] two hours 20
minutes I got a life so uh it's
definitely worth seeing what a great
holiday movie two men like is you know
there's that sequence alone which you've
all seen the trailer where a little boy
Aquaman is that the aquarium and all
this - all the sea life stops and bends
and [ __ ] me that they don't have cuz
they're all fish you know at the king of
the seven seas
that shit's dope man III it's honestly I
is a better Aquaman movie than I ever
imagined we were ever going to get in
this lifetime and you know they deserve
all praising in the world it's a [ __ ]
step in the absolute right direction
for these DC comic book movies quite
like Wonder Woman Wonder Woman and
Aquaman or two steps in the absolute
right direction these is what these
movies should be fun and imaginative and
stuff so uh maybe a little shorter
that's just me but you know what maybe
people are like hey man paying ten bucks
to see this [ __ ] give me all the [ __ ]
movie they do in Aquaman they give you
all the movie it's like they give you to
Aquaman movies and one seriously so
there it is man Aquaman I don't do stars
I do do starfish I give it I don't do
that kind of [ __ ] I don't like to you
know there any thumbs up thumbs down or
[ __ ] four stars I'm just telling you
what I thought and what I thought was I
enjoyed it I saw it like two weeks ago
and there was an embargo where I
couldn't say anything and then my mom
got sick so I was just been than
Christmas and stuff this is the first
moment I had to think about it but not
and I knew we'd be talking about it on
Babylon tomorrow night of both shows
that's right Hollywood babble-on come
bring in the new year Hollywood babble
New Year's rockin Eve New Year's bable
Eve
we call it 7:30 show 10 o'clock show
tickets at cease mod.com SE es mo d calm
show out here in Hollywood of course at
the Hollywood improv well famous
Hollywood improv on Melrose so I knew I
was gonna be talking about so I figure
oh [ __ ] maybe I better talk about it now
at Great Lengths because on the show
I'll probably just sit there and be like
yeah it was fun Ralph and then move the
[ __ ] out so yeah clearly I didn't deep
dive on this as long as I did on
spider-man into the spider verse with
Marc but that movie you know that's
extraordinary
like a piece of animation Aquaman
wonderful movie this is this is what
movies are supposed to be man take you
to a place take me somewhere man take me
into water you know watery movies have
captured my imagination forever jaws is
one of the first movies I remember
seeing saw the Gumball Rally first then
Jaws in a drive-in 1975 and we grew up
in a beach town so I could have been at
the ocean every day in my life
with a rocking bod maybe like Jason
Momoa but oh no I saw jaws and [ __ ]
Steven Spielberg ruined the ocean for me
he probably saved my life honestly cuz
what the [ __ ] I got no business going in
there you go in the ocean you're gonna
get eaten like it's entering the food
chain at the wrong side so Steven
Spielberg probably saved my life but
yeah I love watery movies man movies
going underwater and [ __ ] like that I
love any movie got a shark in it you
weaponize [ __ ] shark and throw it at
an enemy [ __ ] it take all my money so
I'm I love what they did with Aquaman
hats off to James one I look forward to
the next one a man no filmmaker wants to
hear that took forever to make this
movie man and I'm like what's next man
we doing another one but they're off and
running so I look forward to the next
one there it is man Aquaman go check it
out it's in theaters right now I got no
skin in the game I'm just talking as a
fan and stuff every once in a while
people like a book and you're on the DC
payroll my daughters on the DC payroll
she works for DC daily over a DC
Universe app so if you uh if you see her
over there crowing about [ __ ] for DC
chances are you're right when you say
will you book your paper because she is
paid by the Bob
this is just me talking because I I saw
the moving I liked it so uh you know
it's uh it's it's good time but it's a
lot of time two hours of 20 minutes [ __ ]
give it a look-see there it is man
thanks for hanging out
Aquaman fourth scene Happy New Year
everybody
one more day of this wretched [ __ ]
2018 the year I nearly died how I like
to think of it though is the year I
lived so happy new year if I don't speak
to you before then and if you want me to
say that in person
plug plug one more time Hollywood improv
tomorrow night New Year's Eve to show
7:30 ten o'clock Hollywood babble-on
with me and and funny man Ralph Garman
come see us tickets at cease mod.com SE
es mo d calm thanks for hanging out man
DC on the right track next up Captain
Marvel then n game then 20 more years of
Marvel movies
you